Selamat datang kembali di understanding quantum information and computation. Nama saya John Wattress dan saya adalah direktur teknis untuk pendidikan di IBM
Quantum. Ini adalah pelajaran ke-16 dan terakhir dari seri ini dan topik pelajaran ini adalah quantum computing yang fault tolerant.
Selama tiga pelajaran sebelumnya kita sudah melihat beberapa contoh kode koreksi error quantum yang bisa mendeteksi dan memungkinkan kita untuk
mengoreksi error quantum selama tidak terlalu banyak yang terjadi. Jika kita ingin menggunakan koreksi error untuk quantum computing, namun masih ada banyak
masalah yang perlu dihadapi, termasuk kenyataan bahwa quantum gate, pengukuran, dan persiapan state
kita sendiri kemungkinan besar tidak sempurna. Jadi misalnya jika kita akan melakukan koreksi error pada satu
atau lebih qubit yang sudah di-encode menggunakan kode koreksi error quantum, maka kita harus melakukan itu dengan gate dan pengukuran yang sendirinya
bisa saja tidak bekerja dengan benar. Dan itu berarti tidak hanya gagal mendeteksi atau mengoreksi error, tapi juga mungkin
memperkenalkan error baru. Selain itu kita juga perlu melakukan komputasi aktual yang ingin kita lakukan lagi dengan gate yang tidak
sempurna. Dan kita tentu tidak bisa mengambil risiko mendekode informasi quantum demi melakukan komputasi dan kemudian
re-encoding setelah selesai karena error mungkin terjadi ketika perlindungan kode koreksi error quantum tidak ada.
Itu berarti kita harus mencari cara untuk melakukan quantum gate langsung pada logical qubit yang tidak pernah kehilangan
perlindungan kode koreksi error quantum. Ini adalah tantangan besar, tapi diketahui bahwa selama tingkat noise
berada di bawah nilai threshold tertentu, sebenarnya memungkinkan untuk melakukan komputasi quantum yang sangat besar secara andal menggunakan hardware yang berisik setidaknya
secara teori. Dan kita akan membahas fakta yang sangat penting ini nanti dalam pelajaran. Berikut adalah gambaran singkat tentang
pelajaran ini. Kita akan mulai dengan model dasar untuk quantum computing yang fault tolerant termasuk diskusi singkat
tentang model noise beserta metodologi umum untuk mengimplementasikan quantum circuit yang fault
tolerant. Kemudian kita akan beralih ke masalah propagasi error dalam quantum circuit yang fault tolerant dan cara
mengendalikannya. Khususnya saya akan membahas implementasi gate transversal yang menawarkan cara yang sangat sederhana untuk mengendalikan propagasi error.
Meskipun ada batasan mendasar yang mencegah kita menggunakan metode ini
secara eksklusif. Saya juga akan membicarakan metodologi berbeda yang melibatkan apa yang disebut magic state yang menawarkan jalur berbeda untuk mengendalikan propagasi error
dalam quantum circuit yang fault tolerant. Meskipun ini bukan satu-satunya metode yang diketahui dan akhirnya pelajaran
berakhir dengan diskusi yang cukup tinggi levelnya tentang threshold theorem yang saya singgung sesaat lalu.
Teorema ini menyatakan bahwa quantum circuit yang sangat besar bisa diimplementasikan secara andal selama error rate dari semua komponen
yang terlibat berada di bawah nilai threshold finite tertentu. Secara umum nilai threshold ini
bergantung pada kode koreksi error yang kita gunakan serta pilihan spesifik yang kita buat untuk implementasi fault dari
quantum gate dan pengukuran tapi tidak pada ukuran circuit yang diimplementasikan. Dan ini memberi kita alasan bagus untuk percaya bahwa
komputasi quantum skala besar suatu hari nanti akan menjadi kenyataan. Kita akan mulai dengan membahas model dasar untuk quantum computing yang fault tolerant
yang secara alami didasarkan pada quantum circuit dan kode koreksi error quantum. Untuk keperluan diskusi ini
mari kita bayangkan bahwa kita memiliki quantum circuit yang ingin kita implementasikan seperti yang ditunjukkan di sini. Ini kebetulan
adalah circuit teleportasi termasuk persiapan EBIT. Tapi detailnya tidak terlalu penting untuk diskusi ini. Dan kamu bisa membayangkan bahwa
ini adalah quantum circuit lain yang mungkin circuit yang jauh lebih besar yang mencakup persiapan state, operasi
uniter, dan pengukuran. Circuit ini tentu saja mewakili yang ideal, dan implementasi
aktualnya tidak akan sempurna. Pertanyaan alami yang harus ditanyakan adalah apa yang mungkin bisa salah
nah ada banyak hal yang bisa salah. Misalnya inisialisasi state umumnya tidak akan
sempurna. Tentu saja unitary gate tidak akan sempurna dan begitu juga
pengukuran. Dan terlebih lagi qubit sendiri akan rentan terhadap noise termasuk dekoherensi di setiap titik dalam
komputasi bahkan ketika tidak ada yang dilakukan pada qubit ini dan mereka hanya menyimpan informasi quantum. Dengan kata lain hampir
semuanya bisa salah. Namun ada satu pengecualian atau setidaknya itu adalah asumsi umum dan
yaitu bahwa komputasi klasik yang terlibat mungkin tidak akan bermasalah karena untuk semua tujuan praktis
komputasi klasik pada dasarnya sempurna. Jadi misalnya jika kita menjalankan algoritma matching klasik untuk
menghitung koreksi untuk error surface code kita benar-benar tidak perlu khawatir bahwa komputasi klasik ini mungkin bermasalah. Tapi apapun yang secara langsung
melibatkan informasi quantum bisa saja bermasalah. Tentu saja kita membutuhkan model yang tepat yang memungkinkan kita untuk mengaitkan
probabilitas untuk berbagai hal yang bisa salah. Dan jika kita mau kita bisa membuat model yang sekompleks yang kita suka untuk mudah-mudahan mencerminkan apapun yang
sebenarnya terjadi di kenyataan. Namun jika model terlalu kompleks ia mungkin akan sulit atau tidak mungkin untuk digunakan atau untuk mengatakan
sesuatu yang menarik tentangnya. Salah satu contoh model noise yang sangat sederhana yang sering dipertimbangkan orang
adalah model independent stochastic noise di mana error atau kesalahan yang mempengaruhi komponen yang berbeda pada
waktu yang berbeda atau dengan kata lain lokasi yang berbeda dalam circuit bersifat independen.
Misalnya kita bisa mengatakan bahwa setiap gate gagal dengan probabilitas tertentu, bahwa bit flip dan phase flip terjadi pada qubit yang tersimpan dengan probabilitas yang berbeda
per unit waktu dan seterusnya. Tapi asumsinya adalah bahwa tidak ada korelasi antara
error yang berbeda. Sekarang kamu mungkin keberatan dengan model itu karena kemungkinan besar akan ada beberapa korelasi di antara
error. Misalnya mungkin ada kemungkinan kecil error bencana yang menghapus semua qubit sekaligus.
Atau mungkin lebih mungkin terjadi error yang terlokalisasi tapi tetap mempengaruhi beberapa komponen.
Dan tidak ada yang menyarankan sebaliknya. Namun model ini mewakili baseline sederhana yang pada
intinya mencerminkan ide bahwa alam tidak dapat diprediksi tapi tidak jahat dan tidak mencoba untuk secara sengaja
merusak komputasi quantum. Ada model noise yang lain yang bisa dibilang lebih realistis yang sering dipertimbangkan. Dan terlepas dari
model yang kita pilih jika ternyata model kita menyesatkan kita dan kita mempelajari sesuatu yang baru tentang error dalam
sistem apapun yang sedang kita kerjakan kita secara alami bisa merumuskan dan mempertimbangkan model error yang berbeda. Selanjutnya kita akan
melihat strategi dasar untuk mengimplementasikan quantum circuit secara fault tolerant. Jadi mari kita pertimbangkan
quantum circuit logis tertentu artinya quantum circuit ideal yang ingin kita jalankan. Misalnya kita bisa mempertimbangkan circuit yang sama seperti
sebelumnya yang sekarang sedikit diperlebar karena kita akan membutuhkan sedikit lebih banyak ruang untuk implementasi fault tolerant-nya. Pertama
persiapan state unitary gate dan pengukuran tidak akan dilakukan langsung sebagai gate tunggal atau sebagai
pengukuran qubit tunggal atau persiapan state tapi sebaliknya akan dilakukan oleh apa yang disebut gadget yang
masing-masing bisa melibatkan beberapa qubit dan beberapa operasi. Di sini dalam diagram ini saya sudah
mengilustrasikannya dengan menggambar kotak ungu di sekitar hal-hal ini. Dan kamu bisa menganggap kotak ungu ini seperti circuit atau operasi kecil yang
hanya diberi label oleh persiapan state atau gate yang ingin kita implementasikan. Kedua kita perlu melindungi
qubit menggunakan kode koreksi error. Jadi bukan logical qubit itu sendiri yang menghubungkan gadget-gadget berbeda ini tapi gadget-gadget bekerja pada
qubit fisik yang meng-encode logical qubit ini. Dan perlu ditekankan di sini bahwa logical qubit yang kita pedulikan
tidak pernah terekspos artinya logical qubit ini akan menghabiskan seluruh hidupnya dilindungi oleh apapun
kode koreksi error quantum yang kita gunakan. Dan akhirnya kita melakukan koreksi error pada qubit yang sudah di-encode
berulang kali sepanjang komputasi pada dasarnya setiap kali kita punya kesempatan. Dan sangat penting bahwa kita melakukan
ini. Secara intuitif seiring terjadinya error keacakan atau ketidakpastian mulai menumpuk pada state qubit kita
dan kita perlu terus-menerus bekerja untuk menghilangkan keacakan atau entropi ini. Dan ini terjadi melalui koreksi error.
Jadi kamu bisa sedikit menganggap langkah-langkah koreksi error ini seperti lemari es logis kecil atau heat pump yang
memungkinkan logical qubit tetap dingin sehingga komputasi bisa bekerja dengan benar.
Setelah semua pilihan ini dibuat artinya pemilihan semua gadget serta kode dan dengan asumsi model noise tertentu ada
pertanyaan mendasar yang bisa kita tanyakan pada diri sendiri yaitu apakah ini sebenarnya membantu. Apakah kita membuat sesuatu lebih baik atau
kita membuat sesuatu lebih buruk? Jika ada terlalu banyak noise kita bisa saja membuat sesuatu lebih buruk
seperti 9 qubit Shore code membuat sesuatu lebih buruk jika kemungkinan error terlalu tinggi.
Tapi jika noise berada di bawah threshold tertentu maka semua kerja ekstra ini akan membawa kita ke suatu tempat. Dan seperti yang akan kita bahas di akhir pelajaran
jalur terbuka untuk pengurangan error lebih lanjut. Di bagian pelajaran ini kita akan membahas propagasi error dalam quantum circuit yang fault
tolerant yang memiliki struktur dasar yang baru saja saya gambarkan. Ini ternyata menjadi
perhatian utama karena jika kita tidak berhasil mengendalikan propagasi error maka error akan dengan cepat mengalahkan upaya koreksi error kita
tapi jika kita mampu mengendalikan propagasi error maka kode kita akan punya peluang yang jauh lebih besar
untuk mengimbangi sehingga error bisa dikoreksi dengan kecepatan yang cukup tinggi agar komputasi kita bisa
bekerja. Titik awal untuk diskusi ini adalah kesadaran bahwa two qubit gate atau multiple qubit gate lebih
umumnya bisa mempropagasikan error bahkan ketika mereka bekerja dengan benar.
Misalnya pertimbangkan sebuah C not gate. Dan misalkan sebuah X error terjadi pada control qubit sebelum C not gate
dilakukan. Nah X error berfungsi seperti X gate. Dan kita menemukan bahwa
circuit di sebelah kiri setara dengan yang di sebelah kanan di mana X error terjadi pada kedua qubit setelah C
not. Ini adalah propagasi error karena lokasi X error yang tidak menguntungkan di sebelah kiri secara efektif mengubahnya
menjadi dua X error di sebelah kanan. Dan kita tidak akan pernah bisa menghindari ini. Selama kita menggunakan C not gate selalu ada
kemungkinan X error terjadi pada control qubit tepat sebelumnya yang kemudian mempropagasi menjadi dua X error
setelah itu. Tapi seperti yang akan kita lihat selama kita mengambil langkah untuk membatasi kerusakan yang disebabkan ini kita akan baik-baik saja. Dan ngomong-ngomong
fenomena yang sama terjadi ketika kita memiliki Z error pada target qubit tepat sebelum C not. Dan kita membahas ini
sebelumnya dan kamu bisa memeriksa persamaan-persamaan ini dengan hanya melakukan perkalian atau kamu bisa memeriksanya menggunakan
Qiskit. Intinya adalah bahwa ini dalam kedua kasus akan menyebabkan error yang berkorelasi pada beberapa qubit. Dan tentu saja kita
tidak boleh melupakan bahwa C not gate sendiri juga bisa bermasalah yang juga bisa menyebabkan error yang berkorelasi
error. Menambah kekhawatiran kita two qubit gate berikutnya mungkin mempropagasikan error ini lebih jauh.
Misalnya jika kita punya tiga C not gate seperti ini seperti yang kita temukan ketika kita mengukur generator X stabilizer misalnya maka satu error bisa
dengan cepat menyebar ke beberapa qubit. Dan jika ini terjadi dalam satu blok kode misalnya artinya sekumpulan
qubit yang bersama-sama meng-encode logical qubit kode koreksi error apapun yang kita pilih tidak akan punya
kesempatan karena kode dirancang untuk mengoreksi error yang bobotnya rendah bukan error yang bobotnya tinggi seperti ini.
Dan jadi ini adalah sesuatu yang harus kita ingat sebagai prioritas utama sebenarnya saat kita memikirkan gadget dan
langkah koreksi error dalam quantum circuit yang fault tolerant. Cara termudah yang diketahui untuk mengurangi propagasi error dalam fault
tolerant quantum circuit adalah mengimplementasikan gate secara transversal dan saya akan menjelaskan apa artinya itu
sebentar lagi. Jadi mari kita pertahankan gambar implementasi circuit fault tolerant kita di layar hanya sebagai alat bantu visual.
Idenya di sini adalah bahwa untuk beberapa kode koreksi error quantum gate tertentu bisa diimplementasikan secara transversal yang
berarti mengimplementasikannya menggunakan gadget yang merupakan produk tensor dari operasi di mana setiap operasi hanya beraksi pada
satu posisi qubit dalam setiap blok kode. Ini paling mudah dijelaskan melalui beberapa contoh. Yang pertama dan
boleh dibilang paling sederhana adalah implementasi transversal dari poly gate.
Idenya adalah bahwa kita ingin membangun gadget untuk masing-masing gate dalam circuit kita. Dan dalam semua kasus gadget-gadget tersebut
beroperasi pada blok kode seperti yang kita lihat untuk X dan Z gate di akhir circuit teleportasi kita. Tentu saja kita
tidak bisa mendekode menerapkan poly gate dan kemudian re-encode karena itu akan membuat logical qubit tidak terlindungi dan error
mungkin menyebar dalam blok kode sebagai akibat dari re-encoding.
Untungnya kita tidak perlu melakukan itu selama kita menggunakan stabilizer code karena setiap stabilizer code memungkinkan operasi poly
diterapkan langsung pada logical qubit kita. Dan bahkan kita bisa melakukan itu dengan produk tensor dari poly gate
pada qubit fisik yang digunakan untuk encoding.
Misalnya jika kita mempertimbangkan 3x3 surface code yang muncul di akhir pelajaran sebelumnya maka kita bisa mengimplementasikan X dan Z gate pada logical
qubit yang di-encode oleh kode ini dengan mentensor bersama X dan Z gate beserta identity gate dalam pola yang
disarankan di sini. Ini adalah implementasi transversal dari gate-gate ini karena setiap satu operasi gate individual
ini hanya beraksi pada satu posisi qubit dalam setiap blok kode.
Kita hanya menggunakan single qubit gate di sini jadi ini memang agak sepele tapi bagaimanapun juga gadget seperti ini tidak akan menyebabkan error
menyebar. Sekarang salah satu gate individual dalam gadget seperti ini bisa gagal dan itu akan memperkenalkan
error tapi kita selalu akan melakukan koreksi error segera setelah setiap gadget. Dan selama error rate
cukup rendah kode koreksi error akan mengoreksi error-error tersebut.
Dan seperti yang saya bilang ini selalu bisa dilakukan untuk poly gate untuk setiap stabilizer code.
Meskipun kamu memang harus mengidentifikasi pola poly gate yang tepat dalam gadget untuk mengimplementasikan dengan benar operasi poly logis apapun yang kamu
tuju. Untuk contoh lain yang memang melibatkan two qubit gate. Kali ini kita bisa mempertimbangkan implementasi transversal
dari C not gate. Khususnya untuk setiap CSS code kita selalu bisa mengimplementasikan C not gate
antara dua logical qubit dengan hanya melakukan C not gate pada pasangan qubit fisik yang bersesuaian
dan ini memenuhi kondisi transversal karena masing-masing C not gate individual ini hanya beraksi
pada satu posisi qubit dalam setiap blok kode. Misalnya C not gate pertama hanya beraksi pada qubit paling atas
dalam setiap blok kode. C not gate kedua hanya beraksi pada qubit kedua dari atas dan seterusnya
seterusnya. Dalam kasus ini kita bisa memiliki propagasi error karena C not gate mempropagasikan error dan tidak ada
cara untuk mencegah itu. Tapi kuncinya adalah bahwa propagasi error tidak pernah terjadi dalam satu blok kode. Misalnya
X error bisa terjadi pada qubit teratas dari blok kode teratas tepat sebelum gadget dilakukan dan C not pertama
dalam gadget akan mempropagasikan error tersebut ke qubit teratas di blok bawah. Tapi dua error yang dihasilkan
sekarang berada di blok kode yang terpisah. Jadi langkah-langkah koreksi error yang terjadi setelah gadget akan bisa mengoreksi error-error tersebut secara individual karena error-error tersebut
hanya mempengaruhi satu qubit dalam setiap blok kode.
Sebaliknya jika propagasi error terjadi dalam blok kode yang sama maka kita mungkin dalam masalah karena
propagasi error kemudian mengubah error yang bobotnya rendah menjadi error yang bobotnya lebih tinggi yang mungkin tidak bisa ditangani kode kita.
Implementasi ini tidak bekerja untuk kode non-CSS tapi selama kita menggunakan CSS code kita selalu bisa mengimplementasikan C not
gate secara transversal dengan cara ini. Dan untuk satu contoh lagi setiap
Clifford gate bisa diimplementasikan secara transversal untuk steam code. Dan bahkan untuk color code mana pun yang merupakan salah satu hal yang benar-benar bagus tentang color
code khususnya Hadamard gate pada logical qubit bisa diimplementasikan dengan melakukan Hadamard gate secara individual pada
masing-masing qubit fisik dan logical S gate bisa diimplementasikan bukan dengan S gate pada setiap qubit tapi dengan S
dagger gate pada setiap qubit fisik. Jadi intinya adalah bahwa implementasi gate transversal secara inheren
fault tolerant karena mereka tidak pernah mempropagasikan error dalam satu blok kode yang memberi langkah-langkah koreksi error peluang yang layak untuk mengoreksi
error apapun yang diperkenalkan atau dipropagasikan oleh gate yang digunakan untuk gadget-gadget ini. Jadi itu bagus dan ini adalah
cara yang benar-benar sederhana untuk membangun gadget fault tolerant dan ada kode yang berbeda yang memungkinkan implementasi transversal dari gate yang berbeda seperti
T gate tapi sayangnya tidak mungkin bagi kode non-trivial manapun untuk mengimplementasikan
set gate universal secara transversal yang merupakan fakta yang dikenal sebagai Eastin-Knill theorem lebih teknisnya apa yang
dikatakan adalah bahwa selama kode kita memiliki jarak setidaknya dua set gate yang bisa diimplementasikan secara transversal akan selalu menghasilkan
set operasi diskret hingga fase global dan oleh karena itu set ini tidak universal karena set gate universal
selalu menghasilkan operasi yang tak terbatas jumlahnya. Saya tidak akan menjelaskan bukti teorema ini yang menggunakan beberapa
fakta dasar tentang Lie group dan Lie algebra yang bukan prasyarat untuk seri ini. Tapi ide dasarnya adalah
bahwa keluarga infinite dari operasi transversal tidak mungkin membuat kita tetap berada di dalam code space karena perbedaan kecil
dalam operasi transversal teraproksimasi dengan baik oleh operasi poly bobot rendah yang dideteksi kode sebagai
error. Jadi kita sangat senang ketika bisa mengimplementasikan gate secara transversal. Tapi untuk kode apapun yang kita pilih kita tahu bahwa kita
selalu akan memiliki beberapa gate yang tidak bisa kita implementasikan dengan cara ini. Dan jadi kita perlu mencari gadget alternatif. Karena
Eastin-Knill theorem kita tahu bahwa tidak mungkin mengimplementasikan set gate quantum universal secara transversal bahkan
untuk kode koreksi error quantum jarak 2 yang paling sederhana. Jadi kita perlu menemukan cara lain untuk mengimplementasikan gate secara fault
tolerant setidaknya untuk beberapa gate. Salah satu cara terkenal untuk melakukan ini adalah melalui penggunaan apa yang disebut magic
state. Untuk keperluan diskusi ini mari kita ingat kembali S dan T gate yang merupakan
single qubit gate yang didefinisikan seperti yang ditunjukkan di layar. Mari kita juga amati bahwa pertama S adalah operasi Clifford
yang mengikuti dari definisi operasi Clifford kita. Tapi kamu juga bisa memeriksa bahwa mengkonjugasikan poly matrix dengan S selalu memberi kita plus atau minus poly matrix lain.
Dan kedua T bukan operasi Clifford. Dan bahkan jika kita menggabungkan T dengan Hadamard dan C not keduanya
operasi Clifford kita mendapatkan set gate quantum yang universal. Jadi kita tidak bisa mengimplementasikan T gate
hanya menggunakan operasi Clifford dan pengukuran basis standar saja. Tapi kita sebenarnya bisa mengimplementasikan T gate menggunakan
operasi Clifford dan pengukuran basis standar jika selain itu kita memiliki salinan state yang ditunjukkan di sini di
layar yaitu T gate yang diterapkan pada state plus.
State ini disebut magic state meskipun itu bukan satu-satunya yang memiliki sebutan itu.
Istilah magic state juga digunakan untuk merujuk pada state yang berbeda yang memainkan peran serupa dengan yang satu ini dalam variasi dari keseluruhan
skema ini. Misalnya circuit yang ditunjukkan di sini melakukan tugasnya. Dan tidak terlalu sulit untuk memeriksa
itu. Berikut adalah state awal dengan sistem teratas di sebelah kanan. Dan jika kita menerapkan C not gate dan menyederhanakan kita mendapatkan
state yang ditunjukkan di sini.
Jadi jika kita mengukur qubit bawah dan mendapatkan nol yang terjadi dengan probabilitas 1/2 kita tidak melakukan
S gate dan outputnya adalah T yang diterapkan pada s.
Dan jika kita mengukur satu yang juga terjadi dengan probabilitas 1/2 tentu saja kita menerapkan S gate dan hasilnya
adalah sekali lagi T yang diterapkan pada s. Ini bukan satu-satunya cara untuk melakukan ini ngomong-ngomong. Ada cara lain yang tampak serupa
circuit yang menyelesaikan tugas yang sama tapi ini adalah salah satu caranya.
Ini adalah contoh yang agak disederhanakan dari sesuatu yang dikenal sebagai quantum gate teleportation yang saya singgung kembali di pelajaran 4 di mana teleportation digunakan
bukan untuk mengirimkan qubit tapi untuk menerapkan gate. Hubungan dengan teleportation mungkin tidak sepenuhnya jelas di sini karena seperti yang saya
katakan ini adalah versi yang disederhanakan yang bisa kita pakai karena T bersifat diagonal. Tapi jika kamu tertarik untuk
mempelajari lebih lanjut kata kuncinya adalah quantum gate teleportation.
Dan kita juga bisa melakukan sesuatu yang serupa untuk mengimplementasikan S gate di mana kali ini satu-satunya gate yang kita butuhkan adalah C not gate dan Z gate beserta pengukuran
yang berguna jika kita tidak memiliki implementasi transversal dari S gate. Jadi itu menarik tapi tidak
sepenuhnya jelas bahwa ini sebenarnya membantu. Dalam kasus implementasi T gate misalnya kita
berhasil menerapkan T gate pada input state. Tapi untuk melakukan itu kita sepertinya menerapkan T gate pada state plus untuk mendapatkan
magic state. Dan situasinya serupa untuk implementasi S gate. Intinya adalah bahwa kita
tidak selalu perlu pertama membuat state plus dan kemudian menerapkan T gate untuk mendapatkan magic state. Ada cara lain yang bisa dilakukan untuk mendapatkan state ini. Dan
khususnya kita bisa melakukan ini tanpa harus khawatir tentang mempropagasikan error dalam komputasi apapun yang sedang kita kerjakan karena magic state bisa dibuat
secara terpisah. Ini memungkinkan implementasi fault tolerant dari T gate seperti yang akan saya gambarkan sekarang secara singkat.
Pertama kita sebenarnya tidak akan menjalankan circuit dua qubit sederhana yang ditunjukkan di sini tapi sebagai gantinya kita akan menjalankan circuit ini menggunakan
qubit yang di-encode dalam kode koreksi error apapun yang kita gunakan untuk implementasi fault tolerant kita. Yang berarti bahwa
unitary gate dan pengukuran dilakukan oleh gadget fault tolerant. Dan itu berarti kita juga membutuhkan
magic state kita untuk di-encode juga. Jadi segalanya akan fault tolerant selama kita bisa mendapatkan
magic state yang sudah di-encode. Kita mengasumsikan di sini ngomong-ngomong bahwa kita sudah memiliki gadget fault tolerant untuk S gate. Jika
kita menggunakan steam code misalnya kita bisa mengimplementasikan S gate secara transversal. Dan untuk kode yang hal itu tidak bekerja satu opsi adalah
menggunakan seluruh skema ini pertama untuk mengimplementasikan S gate secara fault tolerant dan kemudian menggunakan implementasi itu di sini.
Meskipun itu bukan satu-satunya opsi. Tapi bagaimanapun kembali ke implementasi pertanyaan penting yang tersisa adalah bagaimana kita mendapatkan
magic state yang sudah di-encode mengingat bahwa kita belum memiliki implementasi fault tolerant dari T gate untuk membuat itu
sederhana? Dan ide kuncinya adalah bahwa kita bisa menggunakan proses probabilistik untuk membuat magic state yang sudah di-encode. Dan jika
kebetulan tidak berhasil maka tidak apa-apa. Kita bisa membuang percobaan yang gagal dan mencoba lagi.
Dan itu tidak mengganggu komputasi yang sebenarnya sedang kita coba lakukan karena pembuatan magic state dilakukan
secara terpisah. Cara umum yang dilakukan ini adalah melalui proses yang dikenal sebagai magic state distillation. Dan cara kerjanya seperti
ini. Kita memiliki circuit tertentu yang dikenal sebagai distiller. Kita memasukkan ke dalam distiller ini kumpulan magic state
yang berisik dan kemudian mengukur semua kecuali satu dari output. Dan jika kita mengkondisikan semua hasil pengukuran menjadi nol
maka apa yang terjadi adalah yang keluar adalah magic state yang lebih tidak berisik yang kemudian bisa menjadi salah satu qubit yang dimasukkan ke dalam
distiller lain. Dan proses berlanjut sampai kita gagal karena salah satu hasil pengukuran bukan nol dan kita mencoba lagi atau kita memiliki magic
state dengan kualitas yang cukup tinggi sehingga kita bisa menggunakannya dengan aman untuk mengimplementasikan T gate dalam komputasi yang kita pedulikan.
Ada berbagai cara yang diketahui untuk membangun distiller seperti ini tapi semuanya bekerja dengan cara yang pada dasarnya sama yaitu mereka adalah decoder untuk stabilizer code
artinya mereka adalah invers dari encoding circuit yang bagus karena itu berarti distiller bisa berupa operasi Clifford
Dan akhirnya proses distillation ini sebenarnya terjadi di tingkat logical qubit. Jadi pada kenyataannya ini semua
dilakukan menggunakan gadget untuk distiller dan pengukuran. Proses ini memang harus
dimulai dari suatu tempat. Tapi selama error rate tidak terlalu tinggi memungkinkan untuk membuat magic state yang berisik tapi cukup baik
untuk memulainya. Misalnya dengan menerapkan T gate nyata yang berisik pada qubit dalam state plus dan kemudian
meng-encode qubit tersebut. Jadi itu adalah deskripsi yang sangat tinggi levelnya tapi mudah-mudahan saya sudah memberimu gambaran kasar tentang cara ini bekerja.
Ini jauh lebih rumit dari mengimplementasikan gate secara transversal tapi tetap saja menawarkan cara untuk mengimplementasikan set gate quantum yang universal
secara fault tolerant sedangkan implementasi gate transversal saja tidak bisa melakukan itu. Kadang-kadang diklaim
bahwa overhead untuk menggunakan magic state untuk mengimplementasikan gate secara fault tolerant seperti ini akan sangat tinggi
di mana sebagian besar pekerjaan dilakukan untuk mendistilasi magic state dan menjalankan komputasi aktualnya lebih seperti
pikiran belakangan. Tapi sebenarnya itu tidak begitu jelas dan ada analisis terperinci yang mengungkapkan bahwa metode ini
sebenarnya bisa menjadi praktis. Ada beberapa skema lain yang diketahui untuk mengimplementasikan gate secara fault tolerant. Code deformation dan code switching adalah nama
yang terkait dengan beberapa skema ini dan cara-cara baru terus dikembangkan dan disempurnakan tapi saya tidak akan menggambarkan
metode-metode tersebut dalam pelajaran ini. Ada masalah penting lainnya mengenai implementasi fault tolerant dari quantum circuit dan
itu berkaitan dengan langkah-langkah koreksi error itu sendiri. Jadi ini bukan tentang mengimplementasikan gate. Ini tentang melakukan
koreksi error yang sebenarnya. Masalahnya adalah bahwa jika kita memikirkan circuit sederhana yang
pertama kali kita lihat di pelajaran 14 untuk mengukur generator stabilizer berdasarkan phase estimation kita menemukan bahwa mereka tidak
sendirinya fault tolerant karena mereka berpotensi menyebabkan error menyebar dalam satu blok kode.
Ini kembali ke ide bahwa apapun yang melibatkan informasi quantum rentan terhadap error dan itu termasuk circuit yang sendirinya dimaksudkan
untuk mengoreksi error. Ini tampak cukup bermasalah tapi sebenarnya ada beberapa solusi yang diketahui untuk masalah ini. Saya akan menyebutkan hanya beberapa dari
mereka meskipun saya tidak akan menjelaskan satupun secara rinci. Dan ngomong-ngomong jika kamu mendapat kesan bahwa quantum computing yang fault tolerant
itu rumit dan ada banyak detail yang perlu dikhawatirkan maka itu sangat bisa dimengerti karena memang benar. Ada banyak bagian yang bergerak
di sini dan niat saya dengan pelajaran ini bukan untuk menjelaskan semua detail tapi hanya untuk memberimu pengenalan dasar tentang cara semuanya
bekerja. Salah satu metode untuk quantum error correction yang fault tolerant dikenal sebagai Shor error correction yang dinamai dari Peter
Shor yang pertama kali mengusulkan metode ini. Idenya adalah melakukan setiap pengukuran syndrome menggunakan apa yang disebut cat state
yang sama dengan GHZ state ketika kita memiliki tiga qubit tapi bisa digeneralisasikan ke jumlah qubit berapapun yang sesuai dengan bobot generator stabilizer
yang ingin kita ukur. Khususnya circuit yang ditunjukkan di sini bekerja untuk mengukur generator stabilizer. Dan bisa
ditunjukkan bahwa metode ini tidak menyebabkan error menyebar dalam blok kode.
Ini mengharuskan pembuatan cat state itu sendiri. Dan agar bekerja secara andal dengan adanya error dan gate yang berpotensi bermasalah metode ini sebenarnya
mengharuskan kita berulang kali menjalankan circuit seperti ini dan membuat inferensi tentang di mana berbagai error mungkin terjadi selama
proses tersebut. Metode alternatif dikenal sebagai Steane error correction yang pertama kali diusulkan oleh Andrew Steane dan
metode ini bekerja secara berbeda dan hanya bekerja untuk CSS code. Dalam metode ini kita sebenarnya tidak melakukan pengukuran syndrome pada quantum state yang sudah di-encode
dalam circuit yang ingin kita jalankan tapi sebagai gantinya kita secara sengaja mempropagasikan error ke sistem workspace
dan kemudian mengukur sistem itu dan mendeteksi error secara klasikal. Gambar yang ditunjukkan di sini memperlihatkan cara melakukan ini untuk X error di mana qubit workspace
awalnya diatur ke encoding dari state plus. Jadi ini pada dasarnya adalah
implementasi transversal dari C not gate yang seharusnya tidak melakukan apa-apa karena target ada dalam state plus. Tapi jika ada
X error di qubit teratas mereka akan menyebar ke sistem bawah dan akan terdeteksi. Ada juga metode serupa untuk mendeteksi Z error
dan itu tidak ditunjukkan di sini. Ada juga metode terkait yang dikenal sebagai Knill error correction yang pertama kali diusulkan oleh Manny Knill
dan didasarkan pada teleportation bukan C not transversal dan itu memungkinkannya untuk bekerja untuk sembarang stabilizer code
bukan hanya CSS code.
Hal terakhir yang akan saya bahas dalam pelajaran ini adalah teorema yang sangat penting yang dikenal sebagai threshold theorem. Berikut adalah pernyataan yang agak informal
dari teorema tersebut. Ini menyatakan bahwa jika kita memiliki quantum circuit apapun yang memiliki n gate di mana n bisa sebesar yang kita inginkan maka memungkinkan
untuk mengimplementasikan circuit tersebut dengan akurasi tinggi menggunakan quantum circuit yang berisik asalkan tingkat noise
berada di bawah nilai threshold tertentu yang tidak bergantung pada n. Dan terlebih lagi tidak terlalu mahal untuk melakukan ini dalam
artian bahwa ukuran quantum circuit yang berisik yang diperlukan adalah pada orde n kali pangkat konstan dari logaritma
n. Untuk menyatakan teorema lebih formal memerlukan spesifik tentang model noise yang tidak akan saya lakukan dalam pelajaran ini.
Misalnya bisa dibuktikan untuk model independent stochastic noise yang saya sebutkan sebelumnya di mana error terjadi
secara independen di setiap kemungkinan lokasi dalam circuit dengan beberapa probabilitas yang secara ketat lebih kecil dari nilai threshold ini. Tapi juga bisa
dibuktikan untuk model noise yang lebih umum di mana bisa ada korelasi di antara error. Sekarang ini adalah
hasil teoritis dan cara umum untuk membuktikannya tidak selalu diterjemahkan ke sesuatu yang benar-benar kita lakukan dalam praktik tapi ini tetap merupakan
teorema yang sangat penting dalam istilah praktis. Dan alasannya adalah pada dasarnya mengatakan bahwa tidak ada hambatan mendasar untuk melakukan
komputasi quantum menggunakan komponen yang berisik.
Selama error rate untuk komponen-komponen ini berada di bawah nilai threshold ini mereka bisa digunakan untuk membangun quantum circuit yang andal dengan ukuran
yang sembarang. Cara lain untuk mengatakannya adalah bahwa jika teorema ini tidak benar maka sulit untuk membayangkan quantum computing skala besar
pernah menjadi kenyataan. Ada banyak detail teknis yang terlibat dalam bukti formal teorema ini yang tidak akan saya coba untuk
sampaikan. Tapi saya akan mencoba menjelaskan ide dasarnya pada tingkat yang tinggi. Dan saya juga akan mencoba untuk menghubungkan secara longgar ide dasar
ke apa yang mungkin kita harapkan terjadi dalam praktik. Jadi misalkan ini adalah circuit kita. Ini adalah circuit yang sama yang
sudah kita bicarakan selama pelajaran ini. Tapi sekali lagi kita bisa membayangkan bahwa circuit kita jauh lebih besar dan lebih rumit dari ini. Kita ingin
mengimplementasikan circuit ini tapi semua komponen kita berisik. Dan dengan asumsi kita menggunakan model independent stochastic noise
hanya untuk kesederhanaan ada probabilitas P di mana error terjadi secara independen di setiap kemungkinan lokasi.
Jika circuit jauh lebih besar dari kebalikan dari probabilitas P ini maka kita bisa cukup yakin bahwa
implementasi langsung dari circuit tersebut tidak akan bekerja dengan benar. Jadi kita melalui semua urusan mengimplementasikan circuit
secara fault tolerant seperti yang sudah saya bahas hingga saat ini dalam pelajaran dan kita menanyakan pada diri sendiri pertanyaan yang saya ajukan sebelumnya yaitu apakah kita membuat sesuatu
lebih baik atau lebih buruk? Nah jika probabilitas P yang mewakili probabilitas error untuk masing-masing komponen kita terlalu besar maka
ini tidak akan membantu seperti halnya 9 qubit Shore code tidak membantu jika probabilitas error di atas 3 dan 3/4% atau lebih.
Khususnya kita sekarang sudah membuat circuit lebih besar. Jadi ada lebih banyak lokasi di mana error bisa terjadi.
Namun jika P cukup kecil ini akan membantu. Dan apa yang secara efektif kita lakukan adalah mengurangi
probabilitas error untuk komputasi logis yang sedang kita lakukan. Jadi mari kita pikirkan tentang ini dalam
sedikit lebih banyak detail. Dan untuk melihat ide-ide utama dalam seting sesederhana mungkin misalkan kita menggunakan 7 qubit Steane code untuk koreksi
error yang memungkinkan koreksi hingga satu error per blok kode. Jadi agar terjadi logical error
dalam circuit asli kita harus memiliki setidaknya dua error yang jatuh ke dalam blok kode yang sama untuk implementasi fault tolerant
kita.
Mengingat bahwa ada banyak cara berbeda untuk memiliki dua atau lebih error dalam blok kode yang sama bisa diargumentasikan bahwa probabilitas
logical error di setiap lokasi dalam circuit asli adalah paling banyak C * P ^ 2 di mana C adalah angka yang bergantung pada kode dan pada
gadget yang kita gunakan. Tapi yang sangat penting tidak bergantung pada ukuran circuit asli.
Jadi jika P lebih kecil dari kebalikan dari C yang merupakan angka yang bisa kita ambil sebagai nilai threshold kita maka ini
diterjemahkan ke pengurangan error. Jadi kerja keras kita dalam mengimplementasikan circuit secara fault tolerant mulai membuahkan hasil
Namun error rate baru ini mungkin masih terlalu tinggi untuk seluruh circuit bekerja dengan benar. Jadi kita perlu melakukan
lebih banyak. Dalam praktiknya hal alami yang harus dilakukan pada titik ini adalah memilih kode yang lebih baik dan gadget yang lebih baik untuk mendorong error
rate turun ke titik di mana implementasi kemungkinan besar akan berhasil.
Secara teoritis cara sederhana untuk berargumentasi bahwa ini memungkinkan adalah dengan melakukan concatenation. Dengan kata lain kita berpikir
tentang implementasi fault tolerant dari circuit asli sebagai circuit logis baru. Dan kemudian kita mengimplementasikannya secara fault
tolerant. Dan kemudian kita melakukan ini lagi dan lagi sebanyak yang kita butuhkan. Dan ternyata ini mengurangi error
dengan sangat cepat. Dan begitulah threshold theorem biasanya dibuktikan di atas kertas.
Saya akan memberikan gambaran yang sangat kasar tentang bagaimana error rate berkurang dengan mengabaikan banyak detail teknis yang diperlukan untuk
membuktikan ini secara formal. Kita mulai dengan probabilitas error P untuk komponen asli kita. Dan jika kita mengimplementasikan
circuit secara fault tolerant error berkurang dengan faktor C * P. Jika kita kemudian memperlakukan implementasi fault tolerant
kita sebagai circuit logis dan mengimplementasikannya secara fault tolerant kita mendapatkan penurunan serupa dalam error rate. Tapi
jika kita memikirkan error rate efektif untuk circuit asli kita menemukan bahwa itu turun bahkan lebih jauh karena sekarang
kita menggantikan error rate P dengan C * P ^ 2 karena itulah error rate efektif setelah implementasi fault tolerant level pertama.
Secara khusus setelah sedikit aljabar kita menemukan bahwa error turun menjadi CP
pangkat 3 * P. Dan jika kita melakukannya lagi kita sekarang memiliki error rate CP ^ 7 * P. Dan jika
kita terus melakukan ini untuk total K level apa yang kita temukan adalah bahwa error menyusut secara doubly exponential dalam K. Jadi kita
tidak perlu melakukan ini terlalu banyak kali untuk membuat error rate menjadi sangat kecil.
Sementara itu circuit semakin besar tapi ukurannya hanya bertambah secara singly exponential dalam K karena dengan setiap
level fault tolerance ukuran circuit kita bertambah paling banyak dengan faktor yang ditentukan oleh ukuran maksimum dari
gadget kita. Dan ketika semua digabungkan dan pilihan yang tepat untuk jumlah
level concatenation dibuat kita mendapatkan threshold theorem. Tapi seperti yang sudah saya sarankan ada banyak detail yang diperlukan untuk membuat ini formal. Jadi
apa nilai threshold ini dalam kenyataan? Nah itu bergantung pada kode dan pada gadget yang kita
gunakan untuk Steane code beserta magic state distillation nilainya sangat kecil dan kemungkinan tidak bisa dicapai dalam
praktik. Tapi menggunakan surface code dan gadget state-of-the-art nilainya diperkirakan sekitar 1%. Yang tidak
buruk. Dan seiring ditemukannya kode dan metode baru kita bisa secara wajar berharap itu akan meningkat sementara secara bersamaan tingkat
noise dalam komponen yang kita bangun akan berkurang. Mencapai titik di mana
komputasi quantum skala besar bisa diimplementasikan secara fault tolerant tidak akan mudah dan tidak akan terjadi dalam semalam.
Tapi teorema ini bersama dengan kemajuan dalam kode quantum dan hardware quantum yang sudah kita saksikan hingga saat ini
memberi kita optimisme yang kita butuhkan untuk terus maju menuju tujuan akhir ini yaitu membangun
komputer quantum skala besar yang fault tolerant. Dan itulah akhir dari pelajaran dan akhir dari seri ini.
Saya benar-benar berharap kamu menemukan nilai dalam seri ini dan jika ya tolong pertimbangkan untuk merekomendasikannya kepada rekan atau teman.
Juga pastikan untuk melihat IBM Quantum Learning untuk kursus dan tutorial tambahan dan berlangganan ke channel YouTube Qiskit
jika belum agar kamu bisa tetap up-to-date dengan rilis konten kita di masa mendatang. Terima kasih sudah
menonton.